هبوط تاريخي شهدته العمله اللبنانيه
الدولار الامريكي بات يساوي اكثر من مئه
الف ليره في ادنى مستوى طبعا تسجله العمله
اللبنانيه منذ بدء الازمه وبالمقابل جوله
جديده من الاضرابات بداتها المصارف
اللبنانيه اغلاق لابوابها امام المواطنين
التزاما طبعا بقرار جمعيه المصارف
اللبنانيه ياتي ذلك مشاهدينا بعد قرار
العوده للاضراب لحين اتخاذ التدابير
القانونيه السريعه لوضع حد لما وصفته
بالخلل في اعتماد معايير متناقضه في اصدار
بعض الاحكام التي تستنزف ما بقي من اموال
المودعين
واموال تعود لجميع المذيعين وليس لبعضهم
على حساب الاخرين فوفقا للوكاله الوطنيه
للاعلام فان اضراب البنوك ياتي في الوقت
الذي تتركز فيه الانظار على الاستجواب
الذي سيخضع له حاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه
القضاء الاوروبي بصفه شاهد ازمه اقتصاديه
خانقه انعكست سلبا طبعا على المواطنين
الذين لجا بعضهم الى الانتحار لاسباب
تركوها في رسائل خاصه تتحدث عن ضيق
المعيشه فخلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
مشاهدينا سجلت ست حالات انتحار لفئات
عمريه مختلفه في عده مناطق لبنانيه فحسب
بيان لقوى الامن الداخلي تم تسجيل
حاله انتحار عام 2022 الا ان هذا الرقم
قابل لزياده حيث كان هناك بعض العائلات
التي لم تبلغ اصلا عن انتحار احد افرادها
خوفا من المجتمع
[موسيقى]